the cia wielded its hand in chile in
1973
and later on even while the senate
struggled to figure out exactly what
that hand was doing the ever active cia
was pushing a strong arm in angola and
then the cia's favorite success story
came to an end the cia in the 70s on
company business
the last in our three-part series
featuring the award-winning documentary
on company business
right now on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
international telephone and telegraph
corporation international headquarters
october 16 1970 personal and
confidential the armed forces boss
general renee schneider is fully aware
of the danger of allende moving in but
he will not move an inch without phrase
okay one retired general guild is all
gung-ho about moving immediately
schneider has threatened to have gyo
shot if he moves unilaterally unless
there's a move by dissident chilean
military elements salvador allende will
be inaugurated as president november 4th
i got an order to go right back to
washington and report to kissinger on
monday october 12th and as when i went
in to see kissinger uh and in the course
of talking to him said that only a
madman would be dealing with this
general vo the dissident general or any
chilean military plotter uh 30 seconds
later he leaped up and he said would you
like to see the president
obviously i didn't know that i had
touched a uh a very sensitive nerve
when i said that only a madman would be
plotting since they were already
plotting
and uh
within five minutes we were walking
across uh the white house and we went
into the oval office of the president as
i came through the door the president
greeted me
and he shut the door and while we were
standing right in front of the door the
three of us he's he started to say uh
smack his fist saying that son of a
[ __ ] that son of a [ __ ] and i must
have looked uh sort of surprised
thinking who me and he said uh
uh
not you mr ambassador you always tell it
like it is it's it's that son of a [ __ ]
i ended and then he led us to the desk i
sat to his left at the big desk and to
his right was kissinger and he launched
into a 10-minute monologue describing
how he was going to smash andy within
the context of an indie government
as if indy was going to be inaugurated
without giving a hint that this plot was
underway
international telephone and telegraph
corporation international headquarters
personal and confidential october 25th
1970.
the elimination of general renee
schneider from the key command post
chief of the armed forces makes allende
and the communist even more vulnerable
than before
general schneider fatally wounded in an
assassination last week has been
described as favorable to allende he is
known to have consistently blocked two
attempts by more determined general
officers
contrary to the general expectation the
military did not move against allende
over the weekend it was believed that
the killing of schneider was a president
to a coup
[Music]
the words
that have been read to you uh
are i remember i believe it should be
suggested that the chile situation
warrants high priority by the entire
administration and that everything
should be done quietly but effectively
to see that allende does not get through
the crucial next six months
what else could those words mean well of
course he'd already been president you
know he's elected by this time right now
you were worried about the next six
months whether he'd get the next thing
because of the
economic situation in chile was getting
critical
and
it would have gotten a lot more critical
if these recommendations had all been
carried through wouldn't it
that's
and that was the purpose of the
recommendations
yes
international telephone and telegraph
corporation washington dc personal and
confidential
subsequent to your call yesterday i
heard from washington and a
representative called on me this morning
he discussed the situation in detail and
he made suggestions the suggestions
follow
banks should not renew credits or should
delay in doing so companies should drag
their feet in sending money in making
deliveries and shipping spare parts we
should withdraw all technical health and
should not provide any technical
assistance in the future the visitor
added the money was no problem he
indicated that certain steps were being
taken but that he was looking for
additional help aimed at inducing
economic collapse
a gigantic cooperation
is bigger than the national budgets of
several latin american countries
together
and bigger even
than that of some of the industrialized
nations
launched a
in the september 1970 elections
[Music]
i accuse the itnt
of attempting
to bring about civil war in my country
the greatest possible
source of disintegration of a country
this is what we
from 1972 to 1973 the same sorts of
operations were going on there to
make it impossible for the allende
regime to govern after earlier attempts
to prevent him from taking office failed
such as the assassination of general
snyder and the attempts to bribe the
chilean congress
later on with the help of the
international lending institutions and
those financial institutions controlled
as part of the united states government
were able to exert the financial squeeze
on chile which resulted in great
difficulty in obtaining short-term
credits
creating
scarcity of many different types of
products then such organizations as a as
the truckers union
had legitimate grievances on which to to
base their complaints
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the cia by financing the truck drivers
and the shopkeepers and the other
organizations which professionals for
example who
[Music]
organized against the allende regime
were able to create the conditions and
the appearances of chaos and
disorganization which will always appeal
to right-wing
discipline-minded military leaders who
will intervene and justify their
intervention on the restoration of
national order of the restoration of
national dignity and the attention of
peace
and this in the case of chile of course
and many other countries is the piece of
the grave for a lot of people
[Music]
i tell you
copenhagen of so many years
i say it with calmness and absolute
peace of mind
i do not have the makings of a messiah
i do not have the attributes of a martyr
i'm a social fighter
who is carrying out a task
the task of the people have given me
let them understand
those who want history to go backwards
and who want to
ignore the will of the majority of chile
without having the flesh of a martyr
i will not take even one step backwards
and i want them to know that i will not
leave the moneta palace until i have
completed the mandate given to me by the
people it is only by riddling me with
bullets that they can stop me from my
determination to carry out the program
of the people
salvador
the day before the core orlando had a
meeting with allende
he came back home around 2 am
and he told me that next day that is the
11 the 11th
they were going to call for a referendum
they had wrote in a speech for allende
to communicate the people that he was
calling a referendum
[Music]
three hours later around 5 30
6 00 a.m the president called
and asked orlando to check about some
movement of troops that
supposedly were taking place in
baltimore orlando did so and realized
that there was not only movement of
troops in valparaiso that all over the
country
and that's how we realized that
the coup that was sort of floating in
the atmosphere
for the past weeks was taking place
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
m
we have now been informed
that
of the death of
lendi
and i'd like to say this
that i do want to express regret
on the loss of life in chile
and particularly that of the chief of
state president allende well my reaction
is that this is of course an internal
affair of chile we all are distressed at
the
plight of the chilean people
uh and the failure really of the allende
government
those principles and practices of
marxism did not apply to chile and the
economy went from bad to worse inflation
was rampant values were destroyed
incentives were gone
people didn't know how to set their sets
of values orlando was taken
for a few
for a few weeks to a horrible place
it's the and
the basement of the
air force academy
and there he was interrogated and there
he saw
hundreds of people being tortured
[Music]
is it conceivable that in princeton some
countries in latin america and take the
example of the coup in chile
that uh that the interests of
chileans at some point might conflict
with the interest of the united states
and then what would be a viable united
states policy vis-a-vis that country for
example uh are the people in chile
better off now than they were under
allende
we'll really know most about that when
we finally have elections in chile and
when will that be
we don't really know
what you've done is um
pose the dilemma
that people who are in clandestine
operations must face many times during
their life
uh sometimes these practitioners have
problems of personal personal ethics and
morality
am i doing something that's not really
good for the people
furthermore i've noted in intelligence
operations that usually we've gotten
into trouble
when we've tried to help people who
didn't really want to be helped very
much
what it boils down to is
is it
really something in our national
interest that must be done
in the past in the atmosphere of the
cold war and even in the 60s
the american public without
question felt that their presidents
should go ahead and be firm on things
like this and be sure that our interests
around the world were stoutly defended
that's beginning to change to some
degree but i'm afraid it all goes back
to that oval office in the white house
and the kind of decisions that are made
there the perceptions that are made
there
otherwise an intelligence organization
or a practitioner of intelligence finds
himself in the position of i don't like
this it really shouldn't be done my
personal opinion is that it's wrong
what do you do then
do you resign and protest
mr kissinger during the time under
uh review was the president's advisor on
international security
affairs and then became the secretary of
state so we needed his testimony to
determine what the administration policy
was toward
chile in this particular period his
presence here should not be
interpreted as meaning that he himself
was ever involved
in
any
plot
to assassinate any foreign figure
[Music]
to you or to anybody else
i've been as polite as i can about it
this is what he's told me to do yes sir
as long as the matter is in the court
i'm saying nothing
what helms simply did in this case when
he saw that he was going to be hanged
he may escape though
he simply
said
all right
here are
roughly 100 items
in which i'm going to demand discovery
on
in the process of my my defense
and if
one read down through the list
it was quite obvious that he was not
going to hang alone
kissinger would hang with him rusk would
hang with him
ford
uh
nixon
and all sorts of other people
and
therefore
he got off with just a slap on the wrist
senator church of course signed the
final report of the church committee
and one of the comments in there was
that cia was not out of control
uh after his investigations in other
words he had first asked her there's a
question as to whether the cia was out
of control a rogue elephant
and uh he was satisfied by his
investigation that indeed no
the house committee com said that far
from the problem being cia being out of
control he thought that it was too much
under the control of presidents and did
their their will over the years
initially in the investigation
we went into the area of the oversight
function of of the congress the
constitution charges the congress of the
united states
with not only enacting laws and
appropriating money but overseeing the
executive branch of government
and in our investigation and overseeing
uh investigating and evaluating the
oversight function of the congress what
we came up with was number one that the
congress of the united states had
totally failed miserably in his
oversight function mr dulles would you
approve congressman lindsay's suggestion
of a watchdog congressional committee
over the cia well i do not favor it but
i think that is a matter for the
congress and the president to decide
primarily
at the present time there are several
committees the armed services committees
and the appropriations committees which
review the work of cia
and i think they're doing a very
competent job the congress is a group
oriented process of 435 people it's
broken down into a number of
major committees and subcommittees
we have several committees charged with
responsibility of overseeing the conduct
of the intelligence community and we saw
a pattern established
a pattern where the intelligence
community would either brief only the
chairperson of the committee with
respect to
various operations and even uh abuses
sometimes they would brief the
chairperson and the ranking minority
member
and in some instances they would rank
would
brief only a few members of the
committee so in a great number of
instances was not the entire committee
that subcommitted that ever was brief
and i have not recalled at any time
historically where the subcommittee
once it had been briefed on questionable
acts by the intelligence community that
they ever took that information to their
full committee and we certainly never in
history had an extraordinary uh session
of the united states congress to look at
the serious nature of the allegations i
prefer to leave it stand where it is
i can't imagine the british parliament
investigating british b4
and i can't imagine the french chamber
of deputies investigating the french
surety
and i can't imagine the russian presidio
investigating the mvd
why is that's absolutely fantastic to
think about
well it's a gathering of intelligence
secretly
and
uh you you've got to use those methods
and when you come out and go to
examining and exposing and analyzing
publicly
everything they do you destroy the cie
there were a number of them that said
quite clearly on the floor of the senate
that they didn't want to know certain
things
one senator referred to if you're going
to have an intelligence service you're
going to have to shut your eyes
take what's coming
[Music]
three months after the day that the last
helicopter left the embassy rooftop in
saigon the ci flew its first plane load
of arms
to angola starting another third world
conflict where the enemy
selected by the cia no one has attacked
us but we've selected an enemy is
supposedly a threatening communist force
supposedly a soviet effort to take over
a part of africa and we were marching in
there to stop them
january 15 1975 the three angolan
liberation movements got together under
the supervision of the portuguese and
agreed to peaceful competition for
elections to run the country
secretary kissinger's reaction was to
say get me an options paper on what we
can do there
kobe came back and ordered the cia
africa division chief to write up an
options paper in a half a day's time
two days after that the first plane
flew to angola with the army
what will the united states do that is
not a subject that i'm free to talk
about is the united states involved in
any way that is not a subject that i'm
free to talk uh can you deny the report
that the cia has been funneling money
into angola i'm just not going to talk
about that
when will the american people find out
exactly what is happening over there
i don't know
they wanted to know were any americans
involved in the conflict and were we
sending any arms in despite our denials
and were we involved with south africa
and were we recruiting the mercenaries
who were showing up there and so then
you started recruiting
this was for the cia were you just
working on contract no no i i'm working
for fnla the fnla is receiving their
money from the cia
we had four uh
it's common knowledge i'm not blowing
smoke on the cia i support the cia
and their activities we had uh well i
can name 24 ci paramilitary specialists
who were inside angola training and
advising and helping to prepare battle
plans and
installing communications equipment and
helping to run the war life and death
are realities in angola
i would assume that virtually everyone
involved there has some degree of
knowledge with respect to
what if any when where why how and under
what circumstance the united states may
or may not be involved in angola
however there is one party that has no
knowledge of
american involvement in war and that is
the united states people there are the
people of the united states and their
representatives
now how do you justify that
the war powers act requires that the
congress be informed before the
commitment of the united states armed
forces in the legislative history
leading up to the adoption of that law
the proposal was made that that would
include any involvement of any
paramilitary or other forces in such
activities abroad
that provision was stricken and was not
adopted by the congress in the
legislative history there were three
foreign white mercenary armies involved
in angola all three of them ci money and
ci management
let me tell you why i do it and uh
because i don't want to wash dishes
i don't want to drive a truck
uh
i
i don't
want to carry a lunch bucket from
eight to five nine to five and have a 15
minute coffee break between 10 o'clock
and whatever it just isn't my style
when the adventurers got to kinshasa
they were briefed by the ci they were
flown into angola and ci aircraft they
were armed with ci weapons the leaders
were briefed every day with cia
photography
of the enemy position
i'd like to ask you
whether or not cia or any american
government institution or department or
agency is involved in recruiting
mercenaries in any official or
unofficial capacity directly or
indirectly it depends how you define
indirectly
they supported the cia supported
president hollande roberto with 25
million dollars in cash and 25 million
dollars in arms
why would uh
the president and dr kissinger want to
go into end goal
i think basically uh two reasons number
one the old cold war rationale of
stemming the soviet tide
wherever that occurs even though that
goes contrary to the entire history of
the african continent just as indeed our
entry in vietnam went contrary to the
history of southeast asia
number two
president mabutu of zaire
has been a supporter of dr kissinger's
policies of u.s policies assisted our
policy in other areas of the world not
just in africa but in the middle east
and his relative
holden roberto is the faction
that we're backing in angola i toured
the northern battlefront with holden
roberto uh in a volkswagen
bus
and we went down to the borudo dande
where a battle had just been fought the
sasa limba road junction
where we could stand in front of this
this
marker that showed how many kilometers
it was to luanda
by early september the mpla our selected
our chosen enemies were winning and our
allies definitely particularly in the
north and the united forces in the south
were on the defensive losing ground our
solution was to fly on two battalions of
zurian para commandos and c-130 aircraft
into the conflict complete with light
armor and uh light artillery
commandos were foreign troops introduced
into the conflict
when the cubans went in fidel castro uh
went on television in havana and spoke
at length of why they had to go in and
he had his ambassador give a speech at
the u.n general assembly announcing
cuba's
intentions and needs the reason they
felt it was necessary to go into angola
the united states was the only major
party involved that was lying about what
it was doing
this imaginative station chief in lusaka
put out the story in which he he
uh reported a totally fictitious scene
in which cuban soldiers had raped some
15 year old ovimbundu maidens
and this was the perfect touch pure
nonsense very much contradictory of what
the cubans were doing and the way they
were conducting themselves in angola but
the right flavor the cia would like to
play with and then he kept that going
for three months was he he had these
same cuban soldiers captured in a battle
he had them put on trial by
uh with uh before a tribunal of these
same women who had been raped
and then eventually executed with
photographs remind you of the trial and
photographs of the execution of these
young women who had been raped killing
the cubans who had raped them
would you consider the soviet's
involvement in angola sirius are the
cubans i think they are very serious
about their involvement there is it
served you elaborate on that point mr
clinton i think the quantity of their
assistance
indicates that they are very serious
about their involvement
as the soviet and cuban involvement
serious enough to warrant some kind of
united states aid
i think i'd leave that to the secretary
of state and president
so mr kissinger's report of yesterday is
accurate that we are bundling several
millions of dollars
to angola through zaire i don't know
what mr kissinger said specifically but
uh i have always found mr kissinger to
be very accurate
is the 25 million or 50 million figure
accurate that is not a subject i'm gonna
talk about
in the south where the cubans and the
mpla had the initiative unita was losing
they were almost helpless so they
brought in the south africans
they being savindi
but also the cia coordinating with south
africa and encouraging them to come into
the conflict which they did
[Music]
by
early november our
ci managers were being beginning to crow
a little bit the lusaka station sent in
a cable saying that in a few days
the mpla's back would be broken
approaching the 11 november independence
date mobutus para commandos tried to
attack luanda this task force of 1500
men and light armor were caught out in
the open and shell rocketed with these
122 millimeter rockets
and after that the united states effort
was out of business
it makes no difference whether united
states uniforms or in any way in angola
any other country but if we are giving
money or weapons or providing any other
support that results in the death of
human beings
then i think to give a technical
response to the question is not
responsive to the gut issue that i'm
raising
cia and the united states government is
in compliance with the decision made
by the congress as to how this question
should be answered
the congress had an opportunity to
require more than it did it did not it
decided not to and in the course of its
decisions in the course of the laws
adopted by the congress it clearly left
a field for this activity senator clark
went on a tour of africa to confer with
all of the southern africa heads of
state about the angola conflict just to
be the congressional authority about the
validity of the conflict
as he traveled we began to get reports
from each embassy he visited of what he
had said to this person or that in the
embassy and it became it began to to
seem very clear that he was not
sympathetic uh to what we were doing so
we sent out uh cables urging everyone to
try harder to keep us better informed of
what he was finding
as he went to the different countries
and then eventually when he was coming
around finally to kinshasa we sent a
cable
ordering the chief of station to see
president mobutu
and president
roberto of the fnla
and prepare them on what they should and
should not say
to senator clark about the situation in
angola the original request by the cia
was for 100 that's correct that's
correct that's my understanding of it
and then when that ran into some
opposite opposition it was dropped down
towards right down to the 28 to 35
million dollar figure that we're now
talking about and and uh what you're
trying to do is force the cia to
eat what it's already
spent don't want to mean
as far as what we've expended in angola
uh to consider that uh
money thrown away that's exactly the way
i view it i just don't want to pay the
further price it's going to be attached
to any further activity on on our part
colonel peter mclease had me fly him up
to the presidential palace in kinshasa
zaire president holden roberto's palace
we met with four cia agents
that
informed us
to evacuate angola they could not
resupply us
with money or arms because of public
opinion in the u.s
president holden roberto took a phone
call
from the state department
and as f and as far as i know it was
from henry
kissinger
he had a conversation with henry
and uh president roberto was very upset
at the
conclusion of the telephone conversation
could you come tomorrow could you just
explain briefly sir what the situation
is just very very
president holden roberto asked us uh if
we would try to hold out without any
support
as long as we could
we told him we would
and that's the reason sal salvador
turned into an alamo
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he went
because he felt what he was doing was
right
he
thought it would take care of our
financial problems
you didn't want him to go down like this
might happen
i knew that it was going to be dangerous
but i had no idea this would
be the result
[Music]
[Music]
washington dc
united states
[Music]
american
our son is uh
imprisoned uh in angola he was convicted
as a mercenary and um what sentence did
he get
16 years
the state department
called us the first part of march and
said that he was missing in angola
the stand that they have taken is that
it's it was not an official venture
and therefore they can't do anything
officially
this is the
their
stand
have you gotten anything at all concrete
from the united states government to
indicate that they are doing anything
i think that
i would
personally appreciate it if you would
direct some of those questions to the
white house
president neta must understand and he
certainly has been given to understand
that the general attitude of americans
towards angola will be
will be seriously affected
by his actions in the case of mr gear
but we cannot permit a basic foreign
policy
to be
to be
dictated
by our concern for the lives of
americans
because this of individual americans
that may be held prisoner
because this would encourage people to
take american prisoners all over the
world
[Music]
you think princess when you were
recruiting people
in conjunction with the cia for angola
that this decision was made by the us
government and they were just going to
back you up the decision was certainly
made a hell of a lot higher up than i
was
you understand what was going on over
there oh not really i mean
i didn't really pay much attention to
what was going on in angola
yeah we didn't pay too much attention to
it until we realized our son was over
there
i'm sure that this is true of many
people
i thought that it was a matter of
real concern
that planted stories intended to serve a
national purpose abroad
um
came home
and were circulated here
and believed here
because
this would mean that
the cia could manipulate the news in the
united states by channeling it through
some foreign country now we're looking
at that very carefully do you have any
people
being paid
by
the cia
who are contributing
to a major circulation american journal
we do have people who submit pieces to
other two american journals do you have
any people
paid by the cia
who are working for
television networks
this i think gets into the kind of
getting into the details mr chairman
that i'd like to get into an executive
session
uh at cbs
we
had been contacted by the cia as a
matter of fact by the time i became the
head of the whole news and public
affairs operation in 1954
certain relationships had been
established and i was told about them
and asked if i'd carry on with them we
have
quite a lot of detailed information
and we
will evaluate it and we will include any
[Music]
evidence of wrongdoing
or any evidence of impropriety
in our final report
and make recommendations
do you
have any
people
being paid by the cia
who are
contributing to the
national
news
services ap and upi
well again i think we're getting into
the kind of detail mr chairman that i'd
prefer to handle an executive session
senator do you think that you'll name
the news organizations
uh that that remains to be decided i
think it was entirely in order for our
correspondents at that time
to make use of cia agent
chiefs of station
and other members of the executive staff
of cia as sources of information which
were useful in their assessments of
world conditions would you say that
continues today
well i
yeah i would think probably for a
reporter it would continue today but
because of all of the revelations of the
period of the 1970s
it seems to me that a reporter's got to
be much more circumspect in doing it now
or he runs the risk of at least being
looked at with considerable disfavor by
the public i think you've got to be much
more careful about it
i don't think there is any possibility
for reform of the cia i gave up my hope
of this after seeing the
poor performance of the
church committee which was infiltrated
by cia people
and to some ex
sabotage to some extent co-opted
i mean the people that were working on
the the news media was a cia guy there
were other cia people involved
and the cia officers themselves say you
know we didn't
church didn't get anything we didn't
give him
we have government agencies like the
congress the senate committee for
example oversight of to oversee the cia
talking about the agency now being under
control and that the abuses of the past
have now been eliminated as if the
agency wasn't under control all along
and as if what they call abuses weren't
ordered by presidents
the main argument is not with the agency
which is an instrument
for policy execution but the main
argument is with
the president and the people outside the
c i a who determine the interests which
have to be protected and how
who determine american foreign policy
and then call upon the cia and other
agencies to execute that policy
when they come to the
conclusion as they have with the
the
expose on the media their connections
with the media
and
uh with with their involvement in uh
drug experiments and so forth
here they knew the information was was
going to come out
there was no way that they could they
could prevent it so
what they did then was uh was to reveal
it themselves uh
and
uh using their their usual uh
uh deceptive techniques say well that's
it that's the end you know we've told
you everything and that's it there's
nothing more
that's all there is to it and then they
just drop the iron curtain and you can't
get
get beyond it what i would like to know
and i know
many other people would like to know
too is not only the history but the
current relations between the cia and
the savak in iran for example imagine
all the iranians who would like to know
that with the kofkan tv in indonesia
imagine the 100 000 political prisoners
or so in indonesia right now
who are being
held without trial and have been some
for over 10 years by this security
service which has had its history of
relationships with the cia whether the
institutional relationship continues
with the korean cia right now
with the dina in chile with the dopes
and the kodi and the other organizations
in brazil
with the uruguayan security services
with the argentine federal police there
all of these relationships of the past
probably continue to today in one degree
or another and i don't see how the uh
carter administration or any other
administration can talk about human
rights
while these institutional contacts
remain and while these services receive
in one degree or another support
guidance
and encouragement from the cia
the system is what is wrong the system
is what had
to be changed and should be changed
so that so that the president cannot
direct these kind of activities and
certain congressmen cannot cover for
them and that these men cannot
think in those terms of being completely
immoral
or unethical in
in the conduct of their business
oh
[Music]
i don't know who pulled the
trigger on the pistol that killed
richard welsh
um
i do know that uh
agee in a publication in this country
before richard welch was killed
said our job is to obtain the names of
all cia people we can't anywhere in the
world
obtain a photograph send them overseas
and see that they're published in a
local newspaper and be sure you give the
name and address of their residence
that's what happened in greece agee
declared
at the time his book was published or
perhaps even before in the promotional
period that he was determined
to
wipe out
cia activity fellow was immoral
and
one of the best ways to do this was to
reveal the names of all the cia people
we moved the people so that they
wouldn't be subject to violence uh but
we've had such things as
that had reported that children have
said that their their
their playmates in school have commented
about the fact that their fathers are
mentioned in this book and so forth and
i just think that's a terrible thing for
a man who came in signed an agreement to
keep the secrets that he was going to
learn
in the process of his employment and
then go out and violate that agreement i
just think that's plain wrong and i
think it should be punishable
[Music]
in the last three four five years the
world has learned
a lot more than it ever knew before on
what the actual operations were and more
and more people have come to oppose the
secret intervention and the secrets
secret subversion of the institutions in
other countries particularly the people
who live in those countries now i happen
to be on the side of the people who want
to see those operations stopped and
as long as the government of our
government the united states will not
stop the operations then i think that
those
uh interested individuals can do
whatever they can to try to force
these efforts at secret penetration
abroad it's my personal conviction that
mr agee is working for someone else
i can't
mr agee represents a small segment of
the american
intelligence organizations
i've dedicated the idea of
selling everything they can
i call them the kiss and tell boys
i belong to that part that said i signed
a secret seal and as much as i'd like to
come out with some things i'm going to
honor that secret seal
the fact is i never knew welch in the c
i a i never knew phillips either i never
worked with either one of them
and much less did i know that welch was
ever sent to greece
nor did i give his name to anyone
but
they found it very convenient at that
particular point to put the blame for
this on me
during
early 1977 though
through freedom of information filings
in the united states uh secret cia
documents were uh made public
wherein it was discovered that the cia
had in three separate occasions
during the period between welch's
arrival and his uh death about a month
later
the agency in washington the
headquarters had ordered him not to live
in the same house that his predecessor
had lived in
and where his predecessor's predecessor
had lived in and others because they
said in washington everyone in athens
knew that that was the station chief's
home
and
with all of the anti-american feeling
going on in greece at that time
particularly anti-cia feeling
it would be very it would be very
dangerous
welch apparently answered at least on
one occasion saying that he didn't want
to have to drive the extra 20 minutes
he wasn't killed because his name was
richard welch
he wasn't even killed simply was because
he was american or an american
government official
or an american embassy officer he was
killed because of the things that people
know that the cia has been doing in
greece for the last 30 years and that
has been to destabilize every effort of
the people to organize themselves for
change to install some form socialism or
another not a radical
form of socialism necessarily not
communism simply in order to
put in a government of more progressive
forces than the conservatives which the
americans were backing for so long
we have managed to go into country after
country the cia
and
promote dictators to take over the
country
and
with with policies
of suppressing human rights
and
abusing the human rights of the people
in those countries
so that take iran for example
uh this is the favorite success story of
the cia how it installed the shine power
encouraged him to power train the savak
so he could stay in power
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think that uh certainly the united
states has been better off
under the with the shah in command of
iran these last 20 odd years
and i believe also the iranian people
have made more progress
in their social and economic development
in these last 20 years than the
alternative of communist totalitarianism
the whole effort of the united states
then was to keep the shot in power
isha was uh was a steadfast friend of
the united states
through thick and thin
we told him what to do we told him how
to do it
and there was not any any uh
preoccupation with the people
uh there was there was almost a naive uh
trust
uh of of the propaganda coming out of
iran that the people were
were
[Music]
firmly behind the shah
uh the adulation was
spontaneous and all pervasive which was
not which was not true
oh
[Applause]
how would you handle the iranian crisis
differently
i will state the principle that has been
one that i have followed
in my
uh
international operations during the time
that i have been in office and whether
it is in uh vietnam
or whether it is in iran
you don't grease the skids for your
friends
it was 1953 when it was evident to the
shah
that uh some kind of internal security
uh police force was necessary to keep
his opposition in check
he came to the united states and the cia
in particular
cia was instrumental
organizing savak the internal security
police in iran
a senior official at the cia an official
who who i worked under was over for a
period of five years organizing and
establishing sabbath
in savak headquarters in tehran there
were torture rooms
this has been of course well documented
i i saw any number of reports
from
from people who were tortured who saw
the torture rooms describe them in
detail this was a secret place
accidentally they found this place
people and we found it as a place of
torture you can go inside and see it
they used to put
the man they wanted roacher in the first
floor and the heat was coming from the
coke
and hit him and if he would he wouldn't
say anything and resist it with even a
second floor which has more heat and a
fourth floor is that nobody could resist
it was so hot the wood burning
is the human hand which was cut off
this was inside the house
[Music]
the savak's policies towards its own
people are now
uh pretty well documented and the rage
and bitter anger that's being expressed
there towards the united states is a
result of the fact that the people are
quite aware that the savak and the shah
were cie products
the world is tired of political
fanaticism
it is weary of the lies
propaganda and hysteria
created by dictatorships
it is disgusted
by the practice of torture and political
assassination
those people
behind and beyond the iron curtain
have seen so much political wickedness
and cold-blooded betrayal
such godless depravity and government
that they find it harder to believe in
our peaceful intent
and decent motives
than in the calculated and clever lies
that communism is spreading every hour
every day
through every broadcast and newspaper
that it controls
but here in america we pledge ourselves
again
to raise high the light of freedom
to carry on the struggle against its
enemies in every area whether those
enemies be the soviet union castro or
poverty and hunger
until freedom burns brightly
from the arctic to cape horn and freedom
will shine again in cuba
it is the lot of those in our
intelligence agencies
that they should work in silence
sometimes fail in silence
but more often succeed in silence
the awards can never come in public
acclaim
only in the quiet satisfaction
of getting on with the job
and trying to do well
the work that needs to be done in the
interest of your nation
repeat after me please
i stand still turner i do solemnly swear
i stansfield turner do solemnly swear
that i will support and defend the
constitution of the united states but i
will support and defend the constitution
of the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic against all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will well
and faithfully discharge that i will
well and faithfully discharge the duties
of the duties of the office on which i
am about to enter so help me god so help
me god mr director
[Applause]
[Applause]
you